I was thinking about that scene about  Jesse's girlfriend dying on her own  vomit there was a bit of fear on  everyone's part myself included that  that Walt was perhaps going a bit too  far too quickly wake up Jesse wake up  and when that outline uh reached Sony  and AMC and they read it that that uh  that troubled them I remember that scene  more than any other scene that we shot  because while Jane was dying I'm seeing  Kristen Ritter giving her her all and uh  her face then kind of Blends away and I  saw my own daughter's face and I saw my  real child  choking to death and it it scared me  it's an amazing thing to watch it was  one of the rare times when I wasn't  directing that I was there on the set  and I watched standing behind the camera  that scene and as great as the scene is  in the finished product there was  something that I saw in the room that  day that the camera didn't pick up and I  can't put it into words